merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame valérie boyer merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
vous le savez à grande synthe et akalé
la situation est de plus en plus
préoccupante
sur les 6000 personnes qui vivent
actuellement dans ces camps il y environ
10% de femmes âgées de 20 à 30 ans
gynécologues sont frontières nous alarme
sur leur situation
plusieurs d'entre elles distillent
subissent agressions sexuelles viols et
mêmes prostitution d'après les
témoignages recueillis si certaines
femmes sont enceintes volontairement
nombre d'entre elles souhaiteraient
avortée de l'enfant fruit d'un viol
parfois collectif subies pendant la
traversée ou à l'intérieur du camp alors
que nous pouvons nous louer de la
fraternité des européens dont les
français pour l'accueil sur toute
l'europe et la prise en charge de ces
personnes
force est de constater qu'un grand
nombre de migrants ne partagent pas
notre conception du droit des femmes le
13 janvier je vous interpeller au sujet
des violences faites aux femmes à
cologne et dans les camps de migrants le
27 janvier ma collègue marie jo
zimmermann vous interrogez de même comme
vous nous sommes préoccupés par la
dignité humaine par la cause des femmes
mais nos questions demeurent sans
réponse alors je vais vous en pause et
3,3 question simple pourquoi les
migrants sont majoritairement des hommes
alors que nos parents nos grands en sort
et ce en france pour combattre le
nazisme
pourquoi deux jeunes hommes en capacité
de se battre qui composent la majorité
des migrants clandestins ou réfugiées
nul ne le sait quittent leur pays au
lieu de lutter pour leur liberté
c'est vous s'il vous plaît nous dire
pouvez vous nous dire s'il ya en france
des plaines identique à celle de colonne
ou s'il s'agit simple rumeur enfin
quelles actions concrètes comptez-vous
mettre pour protéger toutes ces femmes
il y a deux symboles et le concret pour
notre pays défendre le statut de la
femme est un message fort de l'unité
nationale pour nous mêmes mais c'est
aussi un message fort que nous envoyons
au monde et notamment aux barbares alors
que nous débattons actuellement de la
loi sur la protection de la nation la
liberté l'égalité et la fraternité
doivent concerner tous les citoyens y
compris les femmes pas d'omerta sur ces
questions s'il vous plaît la parole est
à madame pascale boitard secrétaire
d'état chargée des droits des femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
valérie boyer
si nous nous attachons réellement à ces
situations sans en faire une polémique
effectivement vous avez aujourd'hui ces
femmes réfugiées qui sont victimes de
réseaux mafieux qui peuvent les
entraîner dans des systèmes de
prostitution et c'est pourquoi madame
boyer
nous travaillons depuis trois ans sur
une loi d'origine parlementaire pour
lutter contre le système prostitutionnel
et protéger ces femmes pour pouvoir des
mots clés aussi ses réseaux mafieux
deuxièmement il ne nous a pas
effectivement a échappé que ces femmes
étaient en danger souvent seuls car
veuve car leurs maris ont été assassinés
tué par ces barbares dans le pays
d'origine et c'est pour ça que bernard
cazeneuve a mis en place une centaine de
places réservées pour les femmes
notamment à calais que de mon côté je
travaille avec l'ensemble des
associations présentes sur les
différents lieux pour que ces femmes
puissent avoir accès ciel le souhaitent
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
à la protection justement vis-à-vis de
ces violences qui peuvent leur être
opposé
vous voyez madame boyer nous n'avons pas
mis de côté cette question bien au
contraire mais nous n'en faisons pas un
point effectivement de politique
spectacle